[Musica]
non è vero funziona
paura buonasera a tutti scusate la
boutade dello scherzo sono francesco
pezzulli e questa è la mia voce e non
solo infatti la presto a tanti volti
molto più famosi del mio qui ne vediamo
qualcuno tanto per ricordare bene magari
li avete sentiti sherlock benedict
cumberbatch aaron paul in breaking bad
norman reedus in walking dead quello al
centro va bene leonardo di caprio milo
ventimiglia in this is us daniel bruhl
in rush tanti altri eppure devo
confessarvi che ancora oggi quando mi vi
ascolto mi capita di non piacermi
immagino sarà capitato anche a voi chi
quando si riascolta magari registrato su
una segreteria telefonica o su un
messaggio inviato su un telefonino
approvato anche solo per un istante un
senso di orrore alzi la mano
ebbene sappiate che è una cosa
assolutamente normale perché dipende da
un processo psicologico insito in noi
dovuto dal super io censore che è
praticamente una vocetta che è dentro di
noi e ogni volta che parliamo tende a
smontare c a scuola di recitazione a
teatro c'era un esercizio molto utile e
costruttivo che consisteva più o meno in
questo me lo faceva fare un mio mentore
ennio coltorti è un attore era seduto al
centro del palcoscenico si sedeva su una
sedia e recitava il monologo che aveva
imparato a memoria
intanto l'insegnante di recitazione di
girava intorno e ti sussurrava nelle
orecchie le peggio cose tutti i difetti
gli errori e praticamente simulando
quella vocetta che abbiamo dentro
quando ho raccontato questo aneddoto a
un mio amico lui mi ha detto io sono
avvantaggiato sono sposato è questa voce
tacerò tutti i giorni a casa e mia
moglie
quindici sono allenato sono
avvantaggiato allora dicevamo
liberatevi dal senso ipercritico questo
è il mio primo consiglio
imparate a piacervi o quantomeno ad
accettarmi anche perché non esistono
belle voci a volte capita qui abbiamo
ospite un direttore di doppiaggio marco
cortesi che degli attori si propongono
per fare un provino gli dicono una bella
voce posso fare doppiaggio e lui
risponde sempre io ho delle belle mani
posso fare il chirurgo cioè è molto più
importante quello che si comunica con la
voce una voce esiste basta una voce può
essere in tanti modi può essere rauca
può essere graffiata può essere stridula
può essere acuta può essere profonda qui
ho portato due persone con cui ho avuto
il piacere di lavorare che mi fanno
compagnia erano presenti anche alla mia
discussione della tesi alberto sordi e
ferruccio amendola penso le ricordate
tutti probabilmente non li ricordate
tanto per la voce in sé quanto per
quella carica emozionale che
comunicavano quando recitavano alberto
sordi è pure stato la voce di oliver
hardy di stanlio e ollio
e vabbè ferruccio amendola ha dato la
voce a dustin hoffman al pacino a
stallone a de niro insomma ai più grandi
e con quel suo tono rauco sporco e se
vogliamo anche qualche piccolo difetto
di pronuncia quella zeppola penso che
abbia toccato un po il cuore di tutti
noi
quindi dicevamo che non esistono belle
voci però esistono voci educate
quando parliamo non dobbiamo accomodarci
su una tonalità dobbiamo cercare di
modulare dobbiamo anche esercitarci
sulla nostra estensione vocale
potenzialmente noi abbiamo un estensione
vocale che va dalle due alle tre ottave
delle note parlate e attraverso la voce
noi esprimiamo tutte le sfumature delle
emozioni e tutte le sottigliezze del
pensiero umano quindi immaginate che
strumento potente e rivelatorio nel
senso letterale del termine cioè la voce
ci rivela tantissimo quando ci
relazionava una persona allora in questo
senso la voce come strumento rivelatorio
vi sto facendo un discorso in realtà
sperando di lasciarvi qualcosa di utile
non vi voglio parlare strettamente della
del mio del mio ambito professionale che
è quello del doppiaggio della radio
della comunicazione ma sto cercando di
fare con voi anche dei piccoli giochi se
vogliamo che ci possono aiutare a
migliorare l'uso dello strumento
e a prendere consapevolezza c'è qualcuno
più importante di me che ha detto questa
cosa mi sarebbe venuta a dirlo a me è
impossibile non comunicare la detto paul
watzlawick il più grande comunicatore
moderno che cosa affermavamo slavich che
nel momento stesso in cui noi stiamo in
silenzio già stiamo comunicando qualcosa
però il fatto di prendere coscienza di
questo modifica automaticamente il
nostro modo di stare in silenzio la
prossima volta che non staremo fermi
sapremo che anche la nostra fermezza sta
comunicando qualcosa
figuratevi tutto questo applicato alla
voce quando comunicheremo
noi staremo dando qualcosa a qualcuno
allora la voce uno strumento che
argomento di disciplina di numerose
materie che vanno dalla psicologia dalle
scienze cognitive fino all'anatomia
allora permettetemi una piccola
parentesi anatomia veloce sulla anatomia
vocale
il nostro è uno strumento gratuito ed
essendo tale molto molto spesso noi
diamo la dovuta importanza e universale
nel senso che non importa a quale
latitudine ci troviamo
ma in tutto il mondo gli esseri umani
usano l'apparato fonatorio allo stesso
modo
fin da quando siamo piccoli siamo
abituati a sentir parlare di corde
vocali
ecco non è uno strumento a corde ma in
realtà è uno strumento a fiato dove un
muscolo troppo spesso dimenticato che è
il diaframma domina questo strumento e
come un mantice soffia una quantità e
una qualità di aria che fa vibrare le
corde cifra emettere un suono allora se
voi siete d'accordo io prenderei
confidenza con la respirazione
diaframmatica viva insieme
ok staccatevi poco a poco dalla sedia
mettete una mano che all'altezza della
pancia e una sul petto dobbiamo riuscire
a respirare senza muovere la parte
superiore quindi escludiamo la
respirazione polmonare solamente con la
respirazione diaframmatica proviamo a
ispirare per due secondi a ispirare per
due secondi più o meno così
provate perfetto se voi faceste questo
esercizio per una settimana di seguito
la vostra capacita respiratoria
aumenterebbe perché perché il diaframma
e un muscolo e come tutti i muscoli si è
allenato da dei risultati
migliora la respirazione non
dimenticatelo mai
è la nostra il nostro salvagente una
social bella di salvataggio
quante volte vi sarà capitato in un
momento particolare di stress e che vi
hanno consigliato di respirare
profondamente o magari avete avuto la
salivazione azzerata e vi hanno
consigliato di concentrarvi sul respiro
questo perché voce ed emozione sono
strettamente correlate in questo mi
ricollego un po quello che ha detto
stamattina a stefano il neuroscienziato
del web del marketing dove parlava di
emozione e pensiero emozione voce ancora
di più quando uno parla attraverso la
voce si può percepire tutto allora oggi
io vorrei insegnarvi a ridere però solo
se vi va di partecipare altrimenti vado
via subito
lo facciamo allora quando vengono gli
attori di solito al doppiaggio dico non
sa ridere è difficilissimo è una cosa
impossibile perché non sono mai vero
sono sempre finto allora oggi vorrei
fare queste spese cizio con voi perché
perché c'è un guru dello yoga della
risata che si chiama richard romagnoli
che racconta che quando noi ridiamo
abbassiamo il picco di cortisolo
responsabile dello stress e produciamo
endorfine massaggiando il muscolo
diaframmatico allora adesso noi proviamo
a fare dei colpi di tosse così provate
spero che il picco dell'influenza sia
passato altrimenti siamo adesso proviamo
ad avvicinarli tutti quanti siete molto
più bravi di alcuni autori o lavora
adesso leviamo il fiato e proviamo a
inserire il suono più o meno così allora
già lo sapete
avete già fatto che va bene adesso
questa è una risata dal punto di vista
tecnico
a me viene in mente quando rido viene in
mente tonino accolla è stato un
grandissimo doppiatore del passato che
purtroppo è scomparso che era la voce di
eddie murphy insieme al direttore di
doppiaggio uno dei principali che ci
sono stati gara renato izzo avevano
inventato una risata che era quella di
eddy murphy che in originale in inglese
non c'era era più o meno
attraverso questa risata riusciva a
esprimere la psicologia del personaggio
della sua scaltrezza la sua furbizia
allora adesso io vi aiuterò a ridere con
un pensiero cioè quando noi dobbiamo
ridere dobbiamo aprire dei cassetti
emozionali in modo tale da riuscire a
rilassarci facciamo un esempio ridiamo
con le vocali adesso ridiamo con la o vi
aiuto io babbo natale personaggio che
conosciamo tutti grassoccio con la barba
e probabilmente quando bussa alla porta
fa dopo ho provate voi
avete tutti i nipotini lilly si sente
adesso proviamo una risata cattiva la
iena la iena con la gente brava domani
corso di doppiaggio perché sei un os che
va bene potremmo andare avanti con tutte
le vocali non stiamo qui adesso a a fare
questo esercizio che solamente per
capire che le emozioni sono parte
fondamentale della nostra vita è
impossibile non provare emozioni però
possiamo imparare a gestirle perché
imparando a gestirle possiamo ottenere
un risultato migliore quindi quello che
sto cercando di darvi oggi a una
maggiore consapevolezza in voi stessi e
anche un po più di sicurezza
adesso arriva il momento george orwell
tanto caro sbaglio e al grande fratello
alle mighty di boston stanno studiando
delle modelli di analisi vocale
attraverso i quali solo ascoltando una
voce registrata riescono a determinare
eventuali problemi interni ovvero
ascoltando la voce riescono a capire
spiro vocale se qualcuno ha problemi a
livello cardiaco
se qualcuno sbaglia o ha dei problemi di
dizione su alcune sillabe possono
prevenire degli stati di depressione
oppure una non linearità nel suono della
voce può essere una persona soggetta al
parkinson grande fratello provate a
immaginare adesso in un momento in un
mondo fortemente dominato dalla
tecnologia con assistenti vocali come
google alexa sistemi di dettatura
messaggi telefonici inviati and his ear
i down e siri loro riescono a
determinare su una donna il momento nel
momento in cui esatto del suo ciclo
mestruale cioè quindi pensate
all'applicazione a tutte le implicazioni
etiche che può avere la voce perché vi
sto dicendo questo perché la voce è uno
strumento straordinario e purtroppo
tendiamo a darlo per scontato
vi voglio lasciare con un ultimo gioco
un gioco di articolazione ogni volta che
parlo parlo per qualcuno la forma è
importante quanto il contenuto
se non funziona la forma viene
mortificato anche il contenuto
e allora oggi vorrei lasciarvi con un
gioco che ha avuto molto successo a
radio deejay con il trio medusa proposto
insieme a francesco lancia l'autore del
trio durante chiamate roma triuno faccio
un saluto anche al trio che si chiamava
gli vuoi quei kiwi contest qualcuno
perché qualche ascoltatore dj lo conosce
diciamo in dieci secondi quante più
volte potete dei vuoi puoi kiwi siete
pronti li vuoi puoi kiwi li vuoi puoi
kiwi ii wipo i kiwi leeward basta basta
lasciare fermiamoci qui fanno i conti
questo piccolo gioco probabilmente vi
risuonerà nella mente come un mantra
anche dopo che ci siamo salutati
oggi abbiamo fatto un piccolo excursus
sul potere della parola
abbiamo fatto conoscenza col nostro
potere più grande
abbiamo appoggiato alla sua scoperta ne
abbiamo preso confidenza e adesso sta a
voi capire come meglio impiegarla e
visto che il professor corradini ha
citato dante anche io cito dante dante
disse una cosa meravigliosa il primo
vero atto di concepimento non fu l'atto
sessuale dei suoi genitori ma la prima
parola che si dissero grazie a tutti
[Applauso]